bonjour jeoffro Didier merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
vous êtes députés européens secrétaire
général délégué des républicains on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régional bonjour
Christelle du groupe La Dépêche
bonjour d'être là on va évidemment
longement parler de cetteenomination de
Gabriel hatal qui a doncé qui a donc
quelle surprise qui a donc remplacé hier
ellisabeth borne le plus jeune premier
ministre de la République est-ce que
c'est un bon choix Gabriel à d'abord
vous admettrez quand même avec moi que
ce changement de Premier ministre s'est
fait de manière un peu curieuse parce
que pendant 3 jours nous n'avons pas su
si nous allions avoir un premier
ministre de droite ou un premier
ministre de gauche ce qui n'est pas tout
à fait la même chose çaur changer
quelque chose pour vous et puis nous
avons assisté non mais ça change pour
pour les Français de savoir s'ils sont
dirigés par un homme de droite ou
dirigés par un homme de gauche et nous
avons eu droit à une sorte de manège où
nous attendions de savoir quel était le
prétendant du matin ou du soir qui
allait décrocher la queue du Mickey vous
avourez que ce n'est pas sérieux et
surtout que ça indique à quel point
Emmanuel Macron semble perdu le choix a
été fait il s'agit de Gabriel Atal qui
est un homme issu de la gauche mais qui
utilise des mots de droite tant mieux
nous avons bien aiméutilise des mots qui
a fait politique de droite dans les
ministères qu'il a occupé oui oui enfin
nous avons bien aimé effectivement c'est
tout début au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale 5 mois où les mots qu'il a
employé correspondaient à ce que nous
souhtions moi je ne fais pas de procès
d'intention à Gabriel Atal je ne vais
pas l'accuser de ce qu'il n'a pas encore
fait il est jeune il est talentueux mais
la jeunesse l'énergie de la jeunesse n'a
jamais produit un point de croissance et
le talent oratoire n'a jamais fait
réduire un taux de délinquence et puis
un jeune et un talentueux souvenez-vous
en 2017 nous en avons eu un il a même
été élu président de la République et
non pas nommé Premier ministre 6 ans
après on a payé pour voir regarder les
résultats nous avons une dette publique
de 3000 milliards d'euros nous avons un
hôpital public qui est à bout de souffle
avez-vous sans doute peut-être vu que un
couple de donagénre ont dû rester 24
heures aux urgences sans que personne ne
les prennent en charge nous avons un
taux de délinquence avez-vous aussi
peut-être vu les chiffres de la
délinquence 2023 qui viennent d'être
publié par le ministère de l'Intérieur
et qui dit que la l'immense majorité des
indicateurs sont malheureusement à la
hausse avec plus de 1000 agressions par
jour écout ça fait 6 ans qu'Emmanuel
Macron est au pouvoir donc peut-être à
un moment où il va falloir aussi qu'on
regarde son bilan et qu'il tire
lui-même les enseignements de sa
responsabilité ou parfois même de son
irresponsabilité et ça fait 6 ans que
Gabri
l'accompagne et dit amen à toutes les
orientations données par Emmanuel pour
vous la nomination d'un Premier ministre
issu de la droite de la macronie comme
Sébastien le corn ça aurait changé
quelque chose ça aurait été différent je
veux dire le problème ce n'est pas
Gabriel Atal le problème c'est Emmanuel
Macron et je crois que Gabriel Atal
appliquera comme il a toujours fait avec
un talent auratoire ça c'est certain il
obéira à ce que souhaitera Emmanuel
Macron mais moi mon problème orateur
pour vous c'est pas un premier ministre
un porte-parole non mais encore une fois
je pas de procès d'intention personnel à
l'égard de Gabriel Atal nous le jugeront
aux actes en revanche je ne jugerai pas
la communication parce que la
communication on en a souper avec
Emmanuel Macron parce que je ne souhaite
pas uniquement me concentrer sur les
sons les images et les artifices de
communication ce que je souhaite
maintenant ce sont des choix politiques
et je jugerai l'action de Gabriel lthal
au choix politique est-ce que oui ou non
il va par exemple tenir la promesse de
la réduction de l'aide médicale d'État
est-ce que oui ou non à un moment ils
vont comprendre que nous devons
reprendre notre souveraineté migratoire
en mettant sur la table et en faisant
voter un projet loi constitutionnel
est-ce que oui ou non ils vont
s'attaquer enfin au déserts médicaux
est-ce que oui ou non Emmanuel Macron et
Gabriel Atal vont enfin se décider
d'avoir une politique digne de ce nom
sur un secteur économique majeur qui est
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt qui est celui du
logement est-ce que oui ou non ils vont
accepter de rétablir l'université de la
politique familiale voilà ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la seule chose qui
m'intéresse nous pvons commenter tout ce
que vous voulez sur gabrielal sa
jeunesse son talent est-ce qu'il a été
militant du Parti socialiste oui est-ce
qu' aujourd'hui utilise des mots de
droite plutôt oui moi la seule chos qui
m'intéresse ce sont les choix politiques
d'Emmanuel Mac Gabriel Attal aura le
devoir et le fera à mon avis de manière
tout à fait obéissante de mettre en
œuvre alors avant d'en venir au fond
pour rester juste encore de nalité qui
aurait pu trouver grâce à vos yeux
est-ce que une personnalité LR aurait pu
débloquer la situation au Parlement par
exemple la situation en France en
général débloqué vous l'avez dit parce
que la situation est bloquée parce que
la majorité relative est faible et parce
que heureusement que nous avons les
républicains présidés parti pour
débloquer les situations comme ce fut le
cas lors de l'examen du projet de loi
sur
l'IM donc oui moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que euh le gouvernement réussisse
euh que les problèmes soient résolus je
mets honnêtement ma formation politique
et mon le le parti dont je suis l'un des
dirigeants derrière les les mes
priorités pour le pays mais là encore
c'est pour ça que je vous disais il y a
quelques instants le problème c'est
Emmanuel Macron c'est-à-dire que
Emmanuel Macron au fond euh fait
semblant de vouloir travailler avec les
républicains mais ne l'a jamais fait et
les républicains s'imposent à lui et
sont obligés de tordre le bras d'une
majorité à bout de souffle qui a qui
tire et à eu à en permanence pour
obtenir des résultats l'immigration va
peut-être enfin être réduite ce n'est
pas grâce à Emmanuel Macron ce n'est pas
grâce à sa majorité bloquée c'est grâce
au républicains et nous serons une
opposition
rigoureuse responsable qui sur chaque
texte tendra le bras lorsque ce sera
nécessaire de la majorité présidentielle
pour obtenir les résultats au
serviceistre un gouvernement en
coalition ça n'aurait rien changé donc
c'est ce que vous dites mais si Emmanuel
Macron avait pris son téléphone parce
qu'il n'a jamais fait depuis 6 ans et
avait appelé le président des
républicains pour lui dire écoutez venez
nous allons vraiment travailler ensemble
non pas faire semblanc non pas par des
débuchages individu Saint- par exemple
absolument pas mais qu'est-ce qui reste
des rencontres de saint-is rien
qu'est-ce qui reste des convention
citoyennes rien qu'est-ce qui reste du
grand débat qui était censé écouter rien
qu'est-ce qui reste des S jour o
souvenez-vous quand même n'ayons pas la
mémoire courte et le président de la
République avait mandaté ellisabeth
borne pour élargir la majorité rien
qu'est-ce qui reste de tous ces
artifices de communication rien je vais
vous dire une chose puisqu'on est entre
nous Emmanuel Macron n'a de cesse de
faire de la cavalerie c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait il gagne du temps pour durer et la
nomination de Gabriel Atal qui est un
joli coup de
communication durera un certain temps
mais pas longtemps parce qu'on va se
rendre compte encore une fois que les
problèmes structurels sont les mêmes que
le courage à réformer d'Emmanuel Macron
n'est toujours pas là et que la majorité
dont il devrait disposer pour pouvoir
réformer et bloquer mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui geoffroier vous souhaitez
un accord de gouvernement entre les
républicains Gabriel Attal est-ce que
vous souhaitez que Gabriel Atal appelle
Eric Sotil et dirigeant des républicains
que vous mettiez d'accord sur un certain
nombre de textes à une réforme oui ce
n'est pas ce que je demande Emmanuel
Macron je n'y crois pas voilà si ça
avait été vous n'y croyez pas est-ce que
est-ce que vous l' si ça si ça avait été
un une volonté
sincère de travailler vraiment avec les
républicains par un accord rigoureux de
gouvernement comme ça se fait en
Allemagne et qui aurait été inédit en
France il l'aurait fait dès 2017 mais en
fait il a fait tout le contraire
c'est-à-dire qu'il est allé picorer par
des débauchages individuels quelques
individualités qui ne représentait en
rien notre famille politique si ce n'est
leur appartenance passée à un bureau
politique des républicains et il a mené
une politique qui à un moment est à
gauche à un moment est à droite mais
parce qu'il ne peut pas faire autrement
parce qu'en fait il a lui-même était le
fruit et théoriser tout cela
souvenez-vous du en même temps qui
finalement nous mène nulle part donc
Emmanuel Macron ne se renira jamais
là-dessus il n'a aucune volonté de
travailler véritablement avec nous alors
que nous en 2017 nous aurions pu
parfaitement mais non pas par les
débuchages individuels mais par de
véritables accords de gouvernement faire
avancer la France puisque moi c'est mon
seul objectif mais je c r dans une
seconde phase de ce second quinquena
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous le souhaitez
cet accord de gouvernement mais encore
une fois je ne crois pas à la sincérité
d'Emmanuel Macron là-dessus donc on peut
thoriser ce que je souhaite en revanche
c'est que mon pays réussisse donc euh ce
que je souhaite c'est que le projet des
républicains soit mise en œuvre ce que
je souhaite c'est de la clarté avec
Emmanuel Macron nous'ons jamais accord
de gouvernement est-ce que vous avez
encore des Mar de manv de l'espace poli
la meilleure manière de réformer la
France c'est de prendre le pouvoir et la
meilleure manière d'avancer c'est qu'il
y ait enfin une politique claire comme
celle que les républicains promuvent
maintenant depuis quelques années et que
nous avons le devoir de mettre en œuvre
le plus vite possible mais ça ça ne
pourra se faire véritablement c'est ma
conviction personnelle ça ne pourra se
faire véritablement qu'à qu'au moment de
la prochaine élection présidentielle ou
au moment d'une éventuelle dissolution
si nous obtenion une majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée alors avant de parler
d'élection présidentielle à Gabriel
Attal a dit qu'il allait recevoir les
oppositions réellement discuter cette
fois-ci avec elle est-ce que vous
souhaitez que leslr se rendre à se
rendre pardon à ces rencontres et qu'en
attendez-vous est-ce qu'il vous allez
avoir des demandes particulières vous
vous avez dit dans votre question
réellement çavez dire que vous avez vous
venez dire que ça ve dire que nous
sommes d'accord en fait entre nous mais
vous l'admettrez pas moi je le dis pour
vous nous sommes d'accord entre vous que
jusqu'iciici tout ce qui a été initié
par Emmanuel Macron faisait semblant et
n'était que les artifices de
communication moi j'attends toujours les
conclusions du grand débat j'attends
toujours les conclusions des rencontres
de Saint- et je comprends pourquoi Eric
cotti lors de la deuxème rencontre n'a
pas souhaité s'y rendre parce qu'il a
lui-même évidemment vu à la première
rencontre et à l'issue de la première
rencontre que ça ne donnerait rien et
que tout cela était fait pouruser la
galerie aujourd'hui est-ce que les
choses ont changé est-ce que les choses
vont changer avec
Gabriel je souhaite ardemment encore une
fois parce que je veux la réussite de
mon pays mais j'ai du mal cro j'ai du
mal à y croire ça c'est une décision qui
appartiendra au président éicti en tout
cas j'imagine que si le premier ministre
oui si le premier ministre invite les
forces vives de la nation nous y
prendrons une large part mais nous le
ferons sans être DUP nous le on avec
bienveillance parce que parce que nous
avançons de cette manière mais sans
naïveté et surtout avec fermeté parce
que nous avons des réformes à mener
elles sont connues elles sont sur la
table et jusqu'ici elles n'ont jamais
été partagé par Emmanuel Macron vous
pensez à quoi par exemple est-ce que
vous pourriez vous mettre d'accord sur
certains textes mais je je vous prends
l'exemple le plus récent qui soit pour
rafraîchir la mémoire de chacun nous
avions mis sur la table du débat public
il y a quelques que mois un projet loi
constitutionnel qui nous permettrait de
reprendre notre souveraineté migratoire
de faire fi des jurisprudences
européennes qui vont dans le mauvais
sens et qui ne nous permettent pas de
choisir démocratiquement et
souverainement chaque année des plafonds
migratoire et qui ne nous permettent pas
non plus de réduire l'immigration ce qui
correspond au souhait des Français et
bien ce projet loi constitutionnel la
première questionou l'une des premières
questions qu'éoti posera au nouveau
Premier ministre Gabriel Atal c'est
c'est oui ou non est-ce que vous êtes
pour réduire l'immigration et si vous
êtes pour réduire l'immigration est-ce
que vous en êtes prêt à vous donner les
moyens sur la pardon sur ce projet de
loi constitutionnel à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez dû le retirer avant
la fin de l'examen au Sénat il n même
pas pu être examiné parce que les
centristes ne vous ont pas suivi vous
n'avez pas la majorité est-ce que tout
ça de la responsabilité d' Macron ê
minoritaire sur ce sujet bah je croyez
que Emmanuel Macron d'après vos mots
envisager un accord de gouvernement si
Emmanuel Macron dit oui ça ça passera si
Emmanuel Macron ne dit pas oui ça ne
passera pas donc en fait la balle est
dans son camp lorsque nous demandons par
exemple des peines planché pour les
multirécidivistes c'est oui ou c'est non
lorsque nous demandons l'universalité de
la politique familiale c'est oui ou
c'est non la politique la la la balle
pardon n'est pas dans notre camp à nous
la balle est dans le camp d'Emmanuel
Macron et jusqu'ici parce que je juge
les hommes et les femmes politiques aux
actes et non au discours et non aux
Artic office de communication je n'ai
pas vu à ce stade un Yota de volonté de
la part d'Emmanuel Macron d'appliquer
les réformes voulues par la droite
républicaine parmi les les les mesures
que vous demandez il y a la réduction de
la dette du déficit public on a priori
c'est Emmanuel moulin l'actuel directeur
du Trésor qui est un ancien conseiller
d'ailleurs Nicolas Sarkozi qui est un
proche de Bruno leemire qui est
pressenti pour devenir le directeur de
de gabinet de de Gabriel Atal est-ce que
ça laiss s auguré d'une rigueur
budgétaire pour
vous je ne peux pas vous dire dire je ne
connais pas personnellement Emmanuel
moulin s'il a travaillé avec Nicolas
Sarkozi c'est qu'il ne peut pas être
foncièrement
mauvais il est directeur du Trésor donc
manifestement il connaît la tuyoterie de
l'État il n'appartient pas à un
directeur de cabinet d'un Premier
ministre de mener une politique et de la
diriger ça cela revient au terme de la
Constitution au Premier ministre sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
encore une fois la question n'est pas
n'est pas un Ain vous le savez le
directeur de cabin bien sûr bien sûr et
pour des raisons administratives et de
fonctionnement interne de l'État en
revanche les choix politiques ils
appartiennent au président de la
République qui lui jouit d'une
légitimité populaire que je ne conteste
pas donc euh moi ce que je veux savoir
et je me tourne vers le président de la
République s'il nous regarde c'est oui
ou non souhait-il appliquer et mettre en
œuvre et pas faire semblant les réformes
voulues par le président des
républicains et par toute l'équipe de la
droite républicaine si c'est oui on
travaille ensemble si c'est non et je
présage que ce sera non et bien nous
nous opposerons fermement
respectueusement dignement et de manière
républicaine hier Gabriel àal dans son
discours de passation de pouvoir a donné
quelques pistes il a dit que le
gouvernement allait travailler plutôt
pour les classes moyenne et favoriser le
travail c'est des pistes qui vont plutôt
bien non je ne connais pas un Premier
ministre qui sur le perron de Matignon
nous dit qu'il va travailler pour les
classes les plus aisées et bloquer le
travail donc tout ça
c'est de la com pardonnez-moi c'està
direire que ça ne dit rien moi ce que je
veux concrètement c'est savoir si le
taux d'emploi qui est faible en France
contrairement à ce qu'on nous
raconte augmente ou pas ce que je veux
savoir c'est si le chômage qui a baissé
mais comme d'ailleurs partout dans
l'Union européenne ce n'est pas
uniquement le fruit de la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron et qui est en train de
remonter en France va enfin pouvoir être
réduit donc libérer le travail c'est
effectivement simplifier les norme qui
aujourd'hui sont en train de de de de
avec les impôts de production empêchent
les entrepreneurs tous ceux qui innovent
qui prennent des risques qui s' ça fait
partie du pro des projets énoncés hier
par le nouveau Premier ministre ou mais
mais je je l'ai entendu comme vous les
mots étaient doux j'attends les actes et
surtout j'attends les résultats et
malheureusement depuis 6 ans nous
n'avons pas les résultats que nous
souhtions Gabriel a quitté le ministère
de l'Éducation nationale moins de 6 mois
après son arrivée est-ce que vous le
souhaitez qu'il cumule et qu'il reste
encore ministre de l'Éducation nationale
j'ai du mal à croire que cela soit
institutionnellement possible je sais
que ça a déjà existé dans la 5e
République sur d'autres ministère
notamment le ministère de
l'Économie cela lui appartient en tout
cas je crois que la cause de l'école lui
est sincère j'ai estimé que ces premiers
pas même s'ils n'ont duré que 5 mois au
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
allaiit dans le bon sens donc j'espère
que lui à titre personnel et je crois
pour le coup qu'il le fera s'engagera
qu'il soit ministre de l'Éducation
nationale en plus il suffit d'être
Premier ministre pour pouvoir s'engager
aussi pour la cause de l'école le fera
j'imagine quand même secondé par un
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
sera exclusivement sur la cause de
l'école qui est la cause fondamentale
lorsque vous voyez quand même que pardon
je sais que vous voulez passer à un
autre sujet en vous tournant vers
Christel Bertrand mais moi j'insiste
làdus oui ben je je vais profiter de ces
3 minutes pour vous dire quand même que
je m'émeux du fait que la moitié des 16
24 ans en France ne sont pas capables de
dater la révolution de 178
c'est quand même un sujet donc on peut
passer plus que 3 minutes sur cette
cause fondamentale qui est celle de
l'instruction publique qui est celle de
la transmission des savoirs fondamentaux
qui est celle de l'autorité à l'école et
aujourd'hui malheureusement l'école
l'hôpital public l'état des
commissariats et des casernes de
gendarmerie bref les services publics
sont dans un état de paupérisation qui
est pour moi un véritable scandale
d'État auquel le Premier ministre le
nouveau Premier ministre va devoir
s'attaquer Christelle on parle des
européennes oui on choisit
gabrielal à matigon Emmanuel Macron a
aussi souhaité qu'il mène la campagne et
la bataille pour les européennes en face
de Jordan Bardella est-ce que de ce
point de vue là au moins c'est un bon
choix selon vous et est-ce qu'il va être
capable de de challenger Jordan Bardella
ah mais ça c'est une bonne la réponse à
cette question vous appartient c'est
vous les journalistes moi je suis un
acteur public donc moi ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que ce n'est ni Jordane
bardellaa ni Gabriel Atal qui vont
pouvoir réformer l'Europe et qui vont
pouvoir euh faire de l'Europe la
puissance qu'elle mérite pourquoi parce
que d'un côté vous avez Emmanuel Macron
qui est fédéraliste et qui a théoriser
lui-même il l'a dit notamment dans son
discours de la Sorbonne pr une
souveraineté européenne c'est-à-dire une
dilution des souverainetés nationales de
l'autre vous avez un rassemblement
national qui vient chercher sa paye à
Bruxelles mais pour être les fausses
oyurs de l'Europe et qui et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on en commun Marion
maréchal et Jordane bnella appartiennent
à des familles politiques qui ont
toujours combattu le projet européen
donc vous avez d'un côté Emmanuel Macron
qui veut plus d'Europe en France alors
que nous nous voulons plus de France en
Europe et de l'autre vous avez des
formations politique qui ont toujours
combattu l'Europe c'est ni l'un ni
l'autre en revanche nous au sein de
notre délégation et avec François Xavier
béami nous avons mener des combats nous
avons obtenu des résultats nous avons
beaucoup appris lorsque François Xavier
bi dit ces qure vérités au chancelier
Olaf
EUR mais attendez c'est dans 5 mois ça
ça viendra ne vous inquiétez pas lorsque
pour absolument pas vous savez pourquoi
nous sommes pas en retard parce que nous
ça fait 5 ans que nous agissons non pas
que nous parlons parce que nous avons un
bilan un actif alors que on un passif
nous avons une constance dans l'action
nous avons lorsque François Xabier
Bellami dit ses quatre vérités au
chancelier Olaf Scholz notamment sur
l'énergie au Parlement européen lorsque
pour ma part en tant que négociateur de
la première régulation au monde des
réseaux sociaux j'agis pour que les
grands réseaux sociaux les gafas qui
sont aujourd'hui des entreprises aussi
puissantes que des
états enlève soit contrainte d'enlever
les contenus manifestement illicites
comme le harcèlement dont tant de jeunes
sont victimes comme la pédopornographie
ou comme l'apologie du terrorisme ça
c'est de l'Europe concrète c'est de
l'Europe utile vous ne craignez pas que
cette campagne se fasse aujourd'hui
entre Jordan Bardella et Gabriel Atal ce
serait malsin ce serait malsin ce serait
sa que la seule alternative au pouvoir
en place ce soit l'extrémisme et je
pense que nous pouvons être offensif
sans être extrémiste et c'est exactement
ce que nous allons porter nous sommes
animés par une volonté de porter le
projet européen mais aussi animés avec
la même force par l'objectif de remettre
l'Europe à l'endroit parce que trop
souvent elle a régulé là où ce n'était
pas nécessaire et elle a dérégulé là où
il aurait fallu réformer une dernière
question chistal oui pour vous François
Xavier balami reste quand même le bon
candidat parce qu'on est sur des profils
très similaires où est-ce que ça peut
être remise en question d'ici similaire
avec euh là je parlais en terme de de de
sociologie entre Gabriel Atal et Jordan
Bardella on est sur trois profils un peu
euh euh encore une fois ce sont sont pas
des profils ce sont des actions qui sont
menés euh ce sont des délégations qui
ont travaillé euh ce sont des bilans
qu'il va falloir comparer euh et ce sont
euh des volontés politiques il y a une
volonté politique de fédéralisme d'un
côté il y a une volonté politique de MRE
l'UR par terre che Jordan Bella et ses
alliés et une volonté politique de
remettre l'Europe à l'endroit parce que
oui nous sommes proeopéens mais nous
voulons d'abord reprendre la main en
Europe là où c'est nécessaire comme par
exemple sur les questions migratoires
merci je merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité politique la Une de La
Dépêche Gabriel l'homme du Président
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci à
la semaine prochaine on passe au club
des territoire